warning in this video I say zeppeli a
zeppole a lot and to be perfectly honest
with you I'm not quite sure what was
going through my head when I was
recording this but that is just how it
is so please don't rip your dicks off in
the comments section trying to correct
me I already know I'm an idiot and while
I have you here please do subscribe if
you're super keen on moderator content
and maybe we could finally find a series
popular enough to rival all of the hunt
hunter content on this channel anyway
enjoy hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for balls
lots of balls steel ones at that because
steel ball brunt is the thing that I've
been reading and to be perfectly frank I
loved it what a stupidly good story this
was so once again the majority consensus
in my previous Georgia video comments
section was correct and I can see why
many people hold this as far and away
their favorite part of this whole saga
and I have to admit going into it I was
a bit skeptical as I have been about
this entire joder process actually
because each part thus far has been
quite a mixture of high highs and low
lows with the exception of Diamond is
unbreakable which was a narrative format
that just fit our key story telling like
a glove but given that steel ball run is
clearly not a slice-of-life series I
think I had every reason in the world to
be doubtful and I think that only works
in its favor as it consistently blew my
expectations to shreds and replace them
with solid gold which came in many many
forms such as teeth amongst other things
and I think it's because steel bull run
finally sees our key applying his
formula to an action-adventure series to
perfection and what I mean by that is
that our key is clearly a man of
absurdly cool ideas he is one of the
finest creatives in all fiction
consistently able to surprise and
astound me primarily with new stand
abilities and with his supreme talent of
visually depicting them however in my
opinion up until now his weakest point
was finding a way to naturally integrate
those strange abilities into a flowing
story and well explored characters
because to me it has always felt like
the story was more of a stage for the
stand abilities to play on the stands
for the star of the show and every time
a new one pops into existence we need to
forget everything we were doing and
spend a handful of chapters exploring an
admittedly very cool idea but one that
usually has no great future bearing on
the story which can make Jojo feel
painful the episodic at times and like
the story itself is stagnant but still
boron is everything I've wanted from a
Jojo pot from Stardust Crusaders onwards
stands in this part
I used exactly as they should be
assigned element designed to boost the
characters who wield them so for example
while I was reading part seven I don't
think I ever once went right so we've
hit a roadblock now because we need to
defeat this stand thing but rather it
was more a feeling of oh damn
we found a natural obstacle in the form
of this guy who just so happens to wield
a stand or not because not everyone is a
stand user in this series which is also
a very welcome development I don't know
if this makes a lot of sense as far
because I probably expressed it horribly
but I guess what I want to say is that
in steel ball run the characters
themselves outshine their stance and a
primary example of this in my mind is
the character of Ringo who for someone
who only appears in like what three
chapters had an incredibly profound
impact on me but it has almost nothing
to do with his stand but moreso his
mentality and drive his stand ability is
incidental it's a tool for him to use to
achieve his own purposes and a
supporting actor to crafting this brief
but amazing experience that is Ringo
I wouldn't say Ringo is anything special
though and he is in fact very common
occurrence in steel bull run because
most antagonists and other incidental
characters are well defined and
humanized which gives us world over
sudden so much more depth of feel
something that I have not experienced in
Prior parts and I have to praise are key
for finally finding that sweet sweet
balance and for being bold enough to
take the time to write and draw
flashbacks for these characters that
allow us to emot-- with them for a
change and I know that he does do this
selectively for other characters in
previous parts but Stardust Crusaders
diamond is unbreakable golden wind 'red
stone ocean all felt like they featured
a cast of fairly flat stand users
outside of our main group although to be
fair I should give golden wind more
credit than that because I feel like arc
you really did try to flush out the
gaggle of stand users there but steel
ball run is the real deal
and now I refuse to go any further
without talking about our main character
gyro zeppeli which we know because the
manga literally says at one point o main
character gyro zeppeli but I guess he's
technically more of a deuteragonist but
at the same time this incredibly
compelling figure is the driving force
behind so much of this series that I'm
just going to consider him the
protagonist and I love pretty much
everything about gyro his design is
fantastic his story is deep and
empathetic and he also has a nice unique
fighting style via the steel balls which
was a very nice surprise because at this
point I'm very much used to a giorgo
universe where a character can't do
anything whatsoever without a stand
power and while he does eventually
manifest what I think is a stand right
at the climax of this
he spends the majority of his time
facing off against these insane beings
with nothing but a pair of balls
Plus also he decided to take his teddy
with him during the race so what is not
to like about this guy meanwhile al Jojo
for the spot Jonny is also a nice breath
of fresh air in many many ways firstly a
paraplegic jojo is a pretty damn big
deal because he starts the series behind
every other Jojo many of whom were
godlike figures both physically and
mentally from the get-go but Jonny well
he has some serious faults in both of
those areas and that is fantastic
because that is what going on a journey
is all about facing these faults
overcoming them and evolving which Jonny
is in a consistent process of doing all
the way up to the end of steel ball run
and I guess most importantly Jonny
always feels like an underdog especially
with his initially underwhelming stand
ability which is so far removed from the
insanity of stuff like stoned free or
gold experience although through the
focus on rotation Jonny does of course
turn it into an absurdly formidable
power Jonny also gave me pause for
thought though on a number of occasions
because he isn't a simple case of you
know a quote-unquote good guy he is a
very almost morally gray kind of dude
bruh because yes he had an admittedly
tragic childhood and then went through a
phase of being a scumbag of the highest
order but even as we see him in the
modern day sometimes his ruthless intent
goes a bit out of whack
which makes me genuinely question
whether or not I should like him a lot
of the time and that is great I love
that Jonny is not a simple man and that
wid the right framing you could very
easily paint him as a villain but
speaking of villains this series does
have some strict antagonists one of
which is Dyna brando which right cool
wasn't expecting dinosaurs in a Western
but that's what makes Bizarre Adventure
so wonderfully bizarre it will say that
this is almost certainly my favorite
incarnation of deer because while he
retains his British nature to a fault he
also somehow is quite easy to root for
and I was always excited when he showed
up in a chapter as well as any other
alternate-dimension dealers and I tell
you what when one of them popped up
using the world a well I did kind of
lose it that was probably my biggest
moment of shock within the entirety of
steel ball run but it also goes to
highlight that part 7 really cannot
exist without every other part having
contributed to it first and that's
something I was very afraid of after
stone ocean the idea that well we're
done with this universe here's a new one
but the fact that steel ball run
incorporates so much dirt or history
into it makes it a very substantive
experience
as well as well worth taking the time to
closely examine each chapter because you
see names pop up like Stroheim and
Zenyatta Mon da da but then it even goes
a step further and you have these
alternate incarnations like Johnny who
for example is the Jonathan Joestar of
this universe with his father George and
even Danny gets a new form as a mouse
it's just amazing the power that a name
has like for example when you find out
that Lucy's maiden name was Pendleton
and that Jireh was actually a caesar
zeppeli it just fills you with this
great sense of nostalgia but for the
most part it does not hit you over the
head with certain nostalgia rather and
it allows still will run to be its own
unique thing which is a very delicate
balance that I appreciate greatly but
one of the more unique things in the
series is mr. president himself funny
Valentine this guy is intense and that
probably makes a lot of sense
considering he is the embodiment of
patriotism he's interesting though
because he does provide a fairly
attention-grabbing presence whilst also
managing to be a force of disgust
throughout a lot of Steel will run at
the same time towards the end of the
series he does become somewhat
sympathetic due to a nicely constructed
short flashback so I enjoyed that he
wasn't a villain driven purely by his
own selfish motives which is kind of
evocative of Enrico Pucci from part 6
I mean Valentine did talk at great
lengths mind you about taking napkins
specifically taking napkins first and
thus setting off a delightful napkin
chain around the dinner table but in the
end his ultimate duty
was always to his country rather than
himself and there's something quite
admirable about that in its own twisted
way and as for his dance dirty deeds
done dirt cheap well that was just
superb Lee implemented I really enjoyed
the stretch of chapters where the viewer
was trying to figure out the mystery of
who shot Johnny and we get all of these
different perspectives of how it was
whakapapa
or how it was deer or how it was
Valentine himself which was a very
enthralling puzzle to be a part of which
of course all makes sense the end when
we finally learnt the insane ability of
Valentine stand and there's another
thing that endeared me to Valentine the
fact that he was effectively killed off
so so many times but would always pass
his stand and Duty off to an alternate
version of himself which once again
shows a great level of selflessness
actually because a truly selfish person
would never even conceive of such a
thing even if it was just an alternate
version of them they would never want
that to happen but things go well and
truly bizarre once a love trained form
appeared and might I just say in the
digitally colored manga this is some of
the most beautiful artwork I've seen in
the Georgia franchise there's just
something about the way this light is
depicted the
a palpable feeling of or inspiring power
and I think that the world absolutely
needs to see a brilliantly done anime
devotion of steel bull run if only for
this section and there are of course a
ton of other characters to note in part
7 most of which I won't go into once
ganks we just don't have the time but I
will say that the only character I felt
myself wanting more of was Poco Loco
because considering the heat and Sandman
got their own chapter introducing
themselves right from the get-go steel
ball bran I was expecting him to be a
much more profound presence especially
with His infinite luck and his really
fun stand instead we end the series with
him winning the race which is fantastic
I do love the end result but Poco Loco
feels like quite possibly the only
character who was never properly
explored and flushed out now as for the
steel ball run itself I should also say
that this is by far my favorite setting
for a Jojo series from the moment I
found out about it in chapter 1 I was
fully on board because it's so easy to
get invested into a story with an
overarching contest even if that does
eventually get pushed into the
background in favor of searching for a
corpse now actively though it makes an
author's job so much easier
because there is always a prime driving
factor for characters to be moving and
committing the actions that they do so
in steel ball run I never felt like I
was questioning the purpose of the story
as I did come to in part 6 for example
and as much as this may pain me because
I love diamond is unbreakable
steel bull run is probably my favorite
part thus far everything about it is
just so solid it has a brilliant setting
characters containing a lot of depth
interesting stands that don't outshine
their users and - typically bittersweet
Jojo ending where the kid who gyro was
ultimately doing all of this to save
caught a cold and just went and died
anyway which is so tragic that I
couldn't even do anything but laugh at
that point after everything that had
happened fate just went and did its
thing anyway but now it's time to move
on to the last stage of the journey I
guess
Jojo Leon Jojo Lyon Jojo Leon a series
that is still ongoing but we're going to
consume and review it anyway
actually don't know how many chapters
there are but I think it's a substantial
chunk because people have said that it's
been in publication since for 2011 so
even on a monthly basis and
incorporating breaks that is still an
ass-ton of content in 2020 surely and
people have also started asking me about
whether or not I'll continue to talk
about Jojo after I finished a series
like I've had more than a few requests
to start passed an encyclopedia modeled
after the devil for encyclopedia that I
do on my one-piece channel and to be
perfectly honest that is something that
I would love to do however what I don't
know at this stage you should I be doing
on this channel or his JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure such a mega property that it
would need its own channel old questions
that are currently spinning through my
head but that pretty much does it for
this review of the Magnificent steel
ball run if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the new worldview patreon because the
support of all for your amazing people
is what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of Shannara takes place on a
daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on steel ball
run this has been the new world review
and I'll see you next time